Speaker 1: Let's go next to Brian
from Ireland. Brian, welcome.
Speaker 3: Are you, David, sir? How you doing.
Speaker 1: Sir? Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Yeah. First time caller. Thanks a lot.
I was on say thanks very much for. For covering
these debates on the livestreams. It's really
interesting for someone looking from abroad at
the American system. It's pretty interesting.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 3: And my question relates to that as
well. Let's say if somebody in one of these TV
networks put you in charge of arranging the
debate, what kind of changes would you make
to the format? Because and I think you're in
agreement with me here that it's intensely
frustrating. You know, there's never enough time
to develop candidates positions, never enough time
to scrutinize. When Charlie Crist Charlie Crist,
try to ask the scientists some basic questions.
You know, about, well, he served four years. Yes.
And completely ignored him. And that was allowed
by the moderators. No pushback whatsoever.
So how would you arrange this kind of thing?
Speaker 1: So first first and foremost, there have
to be exchanges between the candidates. And in
last night's debate between DeSantis and Crist,
Crist kept trying to get the scientist to say,
I will or I won't commit to serving all four
years. And DeSantis just looked like his brain was
malfunctioning. And then the moderator would jump
in and say, We have agreed that the candidates
will not ask each other questions or address each
other. They will only talk to the moderator. Now,
the candidates seemed to have insisted on that.
Sometimes it's the moderators and the organizers,
organizers who put that in. I think the way we're
really going to learn more is we need longer
periods of less structured back and forth between
the candidates. Bring up the issue of abortion,
for example. Frame it with a question, but
then it doesn't have to be a half hour,
but at least allow 5 minutes of open back
and forth with the moderator being there
to be able to jump in and say, well, hold
on a second, don't talk over each other.
Crist just asked DeSantis this specific question.
DeSantis Can you answer that? And sort of managing
the unstructured time to make sure everybody
gets their points across. We would learn so much
more from that than from 60 seconds. Now, you
respond to me for 30 seconds, but don't talk to
each other. It's just it's too short. It's not the
way we really make progress by talking through a
moderator, talk to each other, but in a way where
we can actually hear what everybody's saying.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I completely agree.
Speaker 1: That's the fundamental
change. I would make more time on
each topic and talk to each other.
Speaker 3: I don't see how anyone halfway
sensible could disagree with you on that and just.
Speaker 1: One minute seem not to want it.
You know, I think they see it as very risky.
Speaker 3: The last thing for me as well.
I also wouldn't have a live audience there
because it ends into a cast as well, but.
Speaker 1: It was totally farcical. Yeah,
absolutely. Brian from
Ireland, appreciate the call.
Speaker 3: Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Appreciate getting
to speak to some of you today. We'll go to a quick
break and be back with more show right after this.